i
loved this i'm having so much fun
watching the show and congratulations to
you guys on the series already getting a
season 2 pick up before it even debuts
because that's just really cool how does
the level of excitement around the
series feel has it sunk it in do you
feel like you're still in your little
bubble since it hasn't premiered yet is
it wild to see people reacting to the
trailer
um
i think honestly we were just saying
that just doing this today has kind of
made it you know it's ramped up how real
it feels we've kind of
been in our bubble in prague for quite a
long time and you know we started
shooting in
2019
i think we flew out in august 2019 so
and we've stopped and started and it's
kind of we've kind of been yeah kind of
hidden away in this little bubble we've
not really known what to expect and
we've kind of had glimpses of the fan
base and stuff like that but just doing
this today and talking to people is
we're like oh we we made a tv show i
made a tv show it's actually coming out
people people have seen that which is
which is lovely that people are finally
getting a chance to see it and i guess
especially because of covid we were
supposed to shoot nine months and it
took us two years
so i get i guess we forgot a bit uh that
we there was an end result you know an
end product uh the actual tv show and i
it still feels like a a little bit of a
bubble because we do this press today
but it's still on zoom so i i guess um
we are getting a lot of time to get used
to this and that the show is coming out
very soon
this
whole thing is absolutely epic when this
project came your way what most excited
you about it was there an aspect of the
genre was it something
about the story was it your specific
character that you were most interested
in
i guess what was unique about this
project and how it came at least my way
was is that i did not know so much about
it i when i when this came my way i knew
it was the wheel of time but it was very
secret so i didn't know what character i
was auditioning for and then you know i
got the part and then they told me who i
was going to play and it was randor thor
and then of course i immediately said
yes i want to play this character but i
always realized like
you know what a character it was and uh
i was aware of his arc and how you know
that he was one of the essential uh
figures in this story and then you know
from that day just starting working and
uh still working and trying to find the
essence of rand today yeah
that's yeah i think the
everything that we've seen just like
this i think the scale of it has just
been something that blew me away i've
done like a couple of little very little
things before but i think
just like the scale of like the size of
the production
the size of the the fan base that
already exists the sets that get built
like um the magnitude of it is still
even now when we're filming season two
it never ceases to amaze me just how big
you know
they can take it with like the stunts or
the sets that they build so um i think
it's yeah yeah you feel very lucky to
work on something where
you know the size of it and scale of it
and the level of production is is so
high
once you guys meet each other i mean you
know you're sort of working with this
smaller ensemble within the bigger
ensemble of actors of this did you guys
all meet each other at once did you sort
of meet each other along the way
through the process of it all
yeah i think i'd i'd auditioned a bit
earlier in the uk
and i think i'm
yeah i'd found out i'd i'd got the part
um
daily and then i was called back to do
chemistry tests
um in london
um
and i think you were yeah
you were there and maddie was there as
well
um
and yeah i remember kind of thinking
like they
i'm not just saying this now i remember
thinking
you i remember like that guy
there's a guy in the corner who's being
quite quiet
he's just got a particular energy
um
and it was just yeah it was just it was
just they clicked and i did i had it
because perrin and gwen have a few
scenes together so we had to had a few
audition scenes and maddie absolutely
smashed it
um so yeah that was the first time
we met i think
yeah i mean it seems like especially you
know your characters all are supposed to
have this history together it seems like
that can be challenging when you don't
necessarily
get to know each other or have time to
figure all that out right away
i i feel
really fortunate that we the chemistry
is that good and it was just uh
yeah i guess it was had to do with the
casting as well they just
it was uh organic and although we had
one one month of prepping and i think
they deliberately made us do all the
stunts together and the horse riding
together we we spent a lot of time that
first month it was like a big summer
camp and uh
and uh
oh sorry there's someone coming in
i don't know who that is
but um but and then
um yeah they're just checking on
spoilers to make sure you don't reveal
anything actually they're like shut up
well it's it's easy to see from
as if you were watching it why you would
want to play these characters and and
you know who doesn't want to play in a
world like this but how deep did you
dive into this world prior to shooting
did you
read the books did you do some other
type of research was there something
that really sort of helped you
in keying into your character and how
they fit into the world
yeah i think i instantly kind of just
started looking at like the whole world
in itself and like and and robert
jordan's work i think
knowing that kind of the structure that
kind of season one was going to take
elements from you know
not only the either world but some of
like the great hunt as well i read that
the first two books just to kind of get
an idea of everything um
but yeah i think it was so helpful to
have that kind of source material there
i mean the scripts were incredible
and
i'd already seen that a few things you
know
had kind of been a change in in a few
little ways but i think having the
script and the books to kind of bounce
between as an actor
is is super helpful and even though it
was quite a daunting prospect you had so
much there to kind of sink your teeth
into which is
quite quite helpful
was it the same for you sir
yeah it was was the same for me when i
uh when i when i got the part i just you
know
i
i went as deep as i possibly could you
know we only had
one month and it felt quite a lot for
such a such a huge amount of material
but you the only thing you can do is um
take it step by step and uh the script
was definitely the main source and um
beside of all the rational stuff and all
the research of the book um that i tried
to read
all of them uh actually
i always felt at home with with the
script um
that's where i felt uh
yeah my um my i had that's where i find
my intuition
and all the research all the material
the books that was available and
everything online as well i i just use
it for my performance you know to try to
get
to understand the character better and
to understand the world of of the weed
of time
how much were you told about ahead of
time i mean did you know what the full
season arc was going to be
for the first season or
did you get some of those details
as the season went along
i mean obviously you know the bigger
story
i think as we went along we we got more
bits and bits and pieces they were also
still writing and rewriting a lot of
scripts that were ahead of us so it was
um at
some points it was um
exciting for us to see what scripts were
coming in and where it was going as well
but we obviously had conversations about
it with rand uh not with rounds
brave uh
yeah always conversations with uh
in the mirror in the mirror
um but yeah yeah i think we yeah we i
think we kind of knew that they would
tend to take um elements from
uh not just the eye of the world but
kind of the second book as well so i
think we kind of knew that
it wasn't gonna just follow
you know one season one book kind of
structure
but um
but you know the characters might come
in at different points kind of and
things but it kind of has to i think
when you're moving from books to tv it's
quite
it's quite hard to throw in everything
at once kind of thing you know it's kind
of you have to establish a lot of
characters um and they're all so
beautifully written in the books so i
think um allowing them to kind of
develop you know at slightly different
stages um i think gives the audience a
chance to really get to know them um as
best as possible
this is a massive world building series
there's the locations the sets the
costumes the language the mythology
there's all of these things the viewer
has to take in
is there anything that most helped you
get into the world and the character
when you got on set was there something
about the wardrobe or the environment or
a prop that you always had that helped
you what what helped you when you got on
set
for me personally the the sets
themselves
have been sort of bit mind-blowing um
the two rivers at the start i think one
of my first scenes i was just kind of
sat on a bench before random matcom
and i just did a 360 and i just saw
you know this village with
children playing and and chickens and
sheep and smoke coming out the chimneys
and people doing their washing and
you're kind of like this is a bit
this is a bit ridiculous that they've
just built
a village for you to kind of facilitate
you to do this scene um so that's
something that
i know it's quite hard not to feel like
you're there
when all of that's been kind of created
around you um the costumes are really
really helpful as well
but i think the sets have been
yeah quite mind-blowing yeah definitely
encourages you but i guess at times it
especially when we first started it's
you know if you arrive in the two rivers
for the first time it's you you realize
what kind of production you're on and
what the scale of it is and
and
not only the sets but also all the
extras all the costumes all the people
that work and set and did the cranes and
and the drones and but i guess then you
just go back to the essence and you know
i guess it doesn't matter if they're
five or six cameras or maybe
one maybe one because in the end it's
about what you do with the performance
and you just respond in a way in the
dialogue that you think is the essence
of
of the character you know
and i guess it and that's where
at least me as an actor where i feel
in at home in in
when i hear action and when i hear cuts
nice
most enjoyed about exploring the dynamic
between rand and glean i mean there's
such a
interesting dynamic to them
how important is that relationship what
can you say about what we'll see from
them this season
i think it's a really important um
relationship because for me it
symbolizes the culture of the two rivers
it's so lovingly and it's so mature you
know they they figure out from a very
young age that love is not uh dependency
it's not jealousy it's not insecurity
and
um
that's really that's really special and
and um i think it's not only the
relationship between rand and and and uh
but also between perry and all the other
characters down the two rivers and and
it's
it feels like a strength and something
they will use have to
use on their dangerous journey
pretty early on we see some horrific
creatures show up and slaughter a whole
bunch of people
and
i mean that's such an interesting scene
or sequence to watch because it starts
from a point of celebration and dance
and then all of a sudden there's all of
this horrific
stuff going on and it feels like that
really sets a mood and tone for what the
series will be
what was all of that like to shoot how
long did all of that take to shoot what
was the
most challenging part of that whole
sequence
um yeah it was it was big i think utah
the director
was sort of
so well equipped for something as sort
of demanding as that i think she knew
that she had to
kind of establish all these characters
but at the same time you know had a huge
epic sort of battle sequence um in that
at the start as well um yeah i think i
think we all had our separate kind of
sequences i think uh rosman and daniel
did a lot of night shoots by some to get
that to get that bit
um finely tuned um i had quite a lot of
stuff in the forge and you with with
michael mountain yeah up mountain but um
yeah when it's all pieced together it it
really does feel sort of quite
relentless when you watch it that
everything
is is sort of happening um at the same
time but um
yeah it was it was good it was quite
good to have a first episode like that
that kind of sets the tone really i
think for the audiences to have that
like you said it's quite
idyllic at the start it's this sort of
like
beautiful sort of village that's quite
um
innocent and naive and then all of a
sudden this sort of darkness comes in
and i think that
you get a sense of what the wheel of
time is from from those two two aspects
yeah i went from going like i would love
to join this party to okay no i wouldn't
really want to be there
okay it looks so fun up until that point
and then yeah
yeah yeah i mean marcus for you in that
fight something happens with your
character that clearly he feels guilt
for
how much will that weigh on him during
his journey is that something that he's
going to continue to think about will it
shape
who he is
yeah i think you know for those who do
know the books but i think you know
apparent has a particular relationship
with with violence and i think he's you
know he's a big a gentle giant but i
think violence is something that he's
always kind of uh struggles with and i
think
having something you know
that he experiences quite early on i
think shapes his behavior going through
season one um and as he kind of enters
the world outside two rivers he realizes
that
you know there's a lot of dangerous
people and and war and battles and
violence is something that he keeps on
cumberland sort of coming across and um
he has to kind of realize does he kind
of let into a
innate animal side that we all have or
is there a way to be civilized and
navigate through
this world
without being violent and i think
it's quite refreshing to have someone to
constantly think should we be you know
be violent or should we be doing this
because i think you know in fantasy is
always someone picks up a weapon quite
quickly and it's always quite cool but i
think there's something quite modern
about someone who thinks you know should
we be
you know embracing a warfare and
actually is there a point to this and is
that the only resolution yeah so um it's
definitely something that peron will
kind of definitely be um embracing as
the season's going
nice yes sir what do you think would
most surprise viewers about what it
takes to make this show what can't we
see just from watching it
what surprised me about the show
what would surprise viewers from you
know about what it takes to make the
show because i mean we're just getting
to watch the
finished version of it but what would
surprise people about what goes into it
what it takes to make it what we can't
see just from watching it there's so
much you can't see you know
we've been you know we've been doing
this for two years
i guess that's the first thing we've
been through pandemic we've been shut
down twice so many
and i mean it was a great experience and
and it brought us closer together as a
group and it made the urgency to tell
the story only bigger but those are all
kind of that's so a lot of stuff that
you you don't see you know i actually
recently
um
my first day of season two i got a food
poisoning you know
that's probably people never will figure
that out until
till now maybe
a lot of stuff going on um on set that
you will um as an audience will never
find out and that's good because um you
know you have to
see the story and not the the the person
behind that character
until we get the behind the scenes look
at it all well
when you get bits and pieces buddy yeah
you